everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over in my opinion one of the best
openings in chess it's fundamentally
sound it has different options for
aggressive players for non aggressive
players but it pretty much hits on all
the opening theories that you have ever
been taught and chest and it definitely
has lots of variations for you to be
creative in your own chess games and it
starts out with Pawnee for Pawnee five
and Knight to c3 and this is the V in a
game there's typically three main lines
that you will see in the Vienna game the
first is Knight to f6 the second would
be Knight to c6 and the third one is
Bishop to c5 we're going to go ahead and
cover all of those today and talk about
many variations that you do have as far
as counteracting that and then looking
at different lines as far as if you want
to be aggressive or if you just want
your standard development and try to
dominate your opponent over the board so
the first one we're going to talk about
is Knight to f6 and White has a few
options in this case now if you are a
very aggressive player like myself you
do have the option of pawn to f4 and a
theme that you'll see a lot in to be in
a game is if you are a Kings gambit
Advocate if you like to play the King's
game it quite a bit this has a lot of
variations that you can kind of play
into the Kings gambit so if you're
pretty familiar with it then this
opening is going to pretty much feel
like home to you so from here there's
basically two responses that black has
he can play the very sharp pawn to d5
and then from here after white captures
with his pawn on e5 then obviously this
Knight has to move he is being attacked
he can come down and capture on e4 and
then white has a few different
variations that he has here he could try
the aggressive Queen to f3 black can
always move this Knight back he can
always try to bring his knight to c6 you
know from here after white captures then
black could come down to d4 you can
start to see a lot of different
complications for white here obviously
Black's putting a lot of pressure
putting pressure on the c2 pawn on this
Queen here on f3 but the same token this
Queen here on f3 is being blocked or
excuse me he's blocking this nights on
g1 to develop so definitely many
variations in this case obviously he may
not want to bring his Queen to f3 he
could always bring his pawn to d3 but
also keep in mind this is blocking off
the light square bishop if he does want
to get into the action a lot of times
you want to bring your Bishop - you know
c4 if you can even de 3 you could always
bring it up to b5 if you wanted to but
definitely especially in the Kings
gambit you want to be eyeing down on the
Kings side of the board as far as you
know the f7 Square so that once you
castle on the King side everything's you
know just staring down at that f7 square
but this definitely is one of your
options and another option you have is
just to bring your knight to f3 again
simple development move trying to
control the center of the board and
trying to put a lot of pressure on your
opponent again you still have this F
I'll open up once you do develop your
LightSquared Bishop you will be able to
castle on the King side and put a lot of
pressure on this F file now again this
is if black responds with a very
aggressive pawn to d5 many times as most
players as I've seen if they play this
they will just take here on f4 and then
white can now play pawn to e5 now this
is a little bit different than what
you're probably familiar with in the
normal Kings gambit where if you just
play you know Pawnee for Pawnee v and
then you sacrifice a pawn once he takes
you're really not going to be moving up
this pawn to e4 because there's really
nothing to attack your but in this case
the knight is here on f6 and so we do
have this attack he's either going to
have to be kicked back right away he can
go back to g8 right away where as you
can see we're going to have a huge
advantage in development or he could try
to bring his Queen to e7 again white
cannot capture with his pawn here on f6
because of the king but then white can
bring his Queen to e2 and again pretty
much stopped any threat and now the
knight is going to have to move again he
can't come to the
five he'll be captured it becomes 2g4
he'll be captured and if he comes to h5
he will be captured so the night will
come back to g8 and then white can
continue his development if you kind of
look at this board this is kind of a
common theme in the gambit of any sort
but especially the King's gambit you
really want to control the center open
up this F file so that when you castle
on the Kings side your rook is just
pretty much staring down on the weak f7
square and you really want to lead in
development obviously you don't want to
give up that pawn early on for no reason
in this case as you can see the Queen
here on e7 isn't doing a whole lot and
none of the other pieces are developed
for black and he pretty much has no
defense for his King and it's going to
be really hard for him to catch up and
development so you definitely definitely
have many different options when you
know if he plays Knight to f6 to begin
the game you can go into that that
gambit with pawn to f4 now I am asked
many times by players they always say
hey Kevin you know honestly I'm not
really an aggressive player I kind of
like to develop all my pieces then try
middlegame really start to form an
attack really figure out where my
opponents at can you go over different
variations that typically are not as
aggressive as you used to plan so
perfect so you definitely have two other
options in this opening as white instead
of playing the gamut here on f4 you have
the simple Bishop to c4 again you
definitely want to develop your
LightSquared Bishop and start to attack
this pawn here on f7 this f7 score is a
huge weakness for white many times if
you studied any amount of Bobby Fischer
games you see that he always like to
bring his Bishop to c4 and later on in
the game he would actually kick his
Bishop back to b3 here very hard to
attack a bishop here on b3 compared to a
bishop on c4 and pretty much he's just
putting pressure on this f7 square the
entire game which is definitely
definitely hard to cope with as a black
player also you do have the option of
Knight to f3 many people are pretty
familiar with the three Knight game
black can even transpose into the four
night game so if you
like to play the three night game but a
lot of times your opponent's not too
familiar with that you see that he's not
playing it if you play Knight to f3 at
the very beginning then if you play the
Vienna game then you might have another
option because if you play c3 and he's
not too familiar he may just bring out a
knight unknowingly and then when you
play Knight to f3 well lo and behold you
are now playing the three Knights game
so you definitely do have options even
if you're not a super aggressive player
you can open it up with Bishop to c4 or
you can always bring your knight into
the game with Knight to f3
now the next variation we're going to
look at is Knight to c6 and you may see
someone play this for a number of
reasons sometimes they're pretty
familiar with the vina game and they
have an entire repertoire of how to to
fitness and they played Knight to c6
because they know what they're doing
other players are not familiar with the
Vienna opening at all and so they see
you played Knight to c3 and they say I'm
not sure what they're doing so I'm going
to mirror exactly what my opponent does
and I'm going to play Knight to c6
because they played Knight to c3 here so
you have two options here again you do
have the very very aggressive pawn to f4
again simple theme that we talked about
before the King's gambit here if he does
take this is a fantastic gambit one that
is very very aggressive but it again you
know if you're an aggressive player I
think you'll really enjoy this and as
you'll see there's a small difference in
the opening as we've seen before but
it's Knight to f3 now if everything goes
according to plan if he plays you know
Knight to c6 if you tries to get
involved he could obviously play you
know pawn to d6 if you haven't watched
the Kings gambit video already I
definitely recommend this to watch that
first but a lot of times you may see
pawn to g5 now if you've seen the Kings
gambit video you see this right away
obviously in this scenario it's a little
bit different the night here on c6 is
placed and we also have our night here
on c3 so from here instead of what we
might typically play you know pawn to h4
then when he comes down we bring our
Knight to g5 instead we're actually
going to
change it up a little bit only in the
Vienna game and then just we're going to
bring our Bishop to c4 we're actually
going to sacrifice night here on f3 so
after the pawn comes to g4 White's going
to castle on the Kings side and after
the pawn takes on f3 then Y it's going
to recapture with his queen on f3 again
putting tons and tons of pressure on
this square f7 obviously if white wants
to he can bring his pawn to d3 or the
for putting pressure opening up this
line for his dark square Bishop to get
involved into the game once this pawn is
off the board as you can see this King
side is already weak the pawn here on g7
is gone and as far as development and
Middle control why it's pretty much just
dominating all over the board so yes
white is down in material but it you
know in the same fashion he is pretty
much leading a lot of different areas of
the game so you may not see the pawn
come down to g5 right away that is one
variation that you may see it's a little
bit different if you are playing the
King's gambit because of how you kind of
want to counter-attack that but just
keep this in mind if you don't see this
again if they just play like normal and
if your Kings gambit player you'll be
pretty familiar as far as getting your
bishop involved into the game castling
on the Kings side and then eyeing up
that rook on the F file play like you
normally would with the Kings gambit so
you do have another option besides the
f4 again everyone's not an aggressive
player and the other option you do have
is Bishop to c4 now there is one extra
thing I want to talk about in this
scenario especially and that is a lot of
times players will try to mare you even
again they may play Bishop to c5 and
this is actually going to be a mistake
from black so if you do see this you
definitely want to take advantage and
the move is going to be Queen to g4
putting a lot of pressure on the the
Kings side for black
he definitely has two options his main
option would be King to f8 or he could
also play pawn to g6 definitely when
your bishop is here on c5 that's really
not one you want to be playing
g6 you really definitely want to be
playing g6 if you're going to be fee and
Kettering your bishop and you have your
bishop here on g7 so this is very good
for for white he can always just come
back kick his queen back to d1 and as
far as a security standpoint why it's
actually going to be pretty fine right
now now he could also try the the one
move he could try Queen to f6 here in
this scenario White's pretty much just
going to allow him to come down and take
this pawn on f2 so he could play Knight
to d5 again attacking that only this
Queen here on f6 but attacking this pawn
here on c7 with a fork of the rook now
if the Queen comes down to f2 the King
can now come to d1 and if you look at it
you say wow Black has a pretty strong
attack but if you if you really look at
all of White's pieces and pawns pretty
much everything is protected the only
piece that's really not protected is
this Bishop here on c4 but pretty much
nothing is is attacking that so all
these Knights pawns are all defended at
any time white could bring his Knight to
h3 start to really attack the the Queen
black doesn't have a lot of attacking
lines that he can really throw at right
away
and White has a lot of different options
that he has he can always bring his
Queen to g7 start to attack he can bring
his knight to c7 you know check the King
make him move so this is going to be a
very very good game for whites going to
be really hard for black even though he
does have this aggressive plan f2 it's
really going to be hard for him to to
find anything else good to play in this
situation so definitely keep this in
mind if you do see black just trying to
Maher all your moves you can always
bring your queen to to g4 and you're
going to be definitely okay from here so
that again is if they open up with
Knight to f6 or if they open up to
Knight to c6 and the last opening that
we are going to look at is if they open
up with Bishop to c5 this is actually
the one variation that I
do not recommend playing the Kings
gambit so playing the pawn to f4 gambit
really because now they could play the
decline line with pawn to d6 but not
only do they have the decline line but
they do have their dark squared Bishop
outside of this pawn chain which is very
very important for black he can always
kick his his Bishop back to b6 if he
wants to he's putting a lot of pressure
on this f2 Square from white which is a
huge weakness for white early on to the
game especially especially for the
King's gambit if as far as the line
trying to castle on the King side we no
longer can do that it's really going to
be difficult for white two to really
cope with this Bishop here on c5 so I
really really don't advocate playing the
the f4 push the gambit front from white
and the scenario instead if he does play
Bishop to c5 you can always just play
Knight to f3 simple development move
from white again trying to control the
center of the board
getting your minor pieces involved
obviously we're attacking both the d5
and the e5 squares if black from here
you know he can always again just play
d6 I think this is a fantastic move from
black again you never want to close off
your pawn chain if you don't have to
unless you have your Bishop of that
color outside the pawn chain which he
does already have but from here if the
players not too familiar with the black
pieces he could play Knight to c6 this
is probably you know it could be a
mistake from here white can always take
with this pawn or he can take with his
Knight with the pawn on e5 and then
after black recaptures then pawn can
come to d4 he can attack both of these
pieces again black can either take and
then you know white can retake again the
Knights going to have to move or one of
the pawns is going to have to move huge
advantage in the middle for white as far
as development same thing he's going to
be in control here if black tries to to
come back he could always come to d6
really block off and hinder the
development of his light square bishop
it's going to be very hard a lot of
black players may not want to give up
their bishop though so
instead of here you could see the night
taken and then the bishop taken right
away and then again as you can see as
far as material is concerned why it is
completely equal with black but white
also has these double bishop pairs so
very good from four White's perspective
if you do see this Knight to c6 instead
of the pawn to d6 again the Vienna game
has so many different variations and as
a defender with the black pieces you may
not be too familiar most players when
they start out with you know pawn to e4
and pawn e5 they're pretty much
expecting either you know Knight to f3
or they could see a lot of players now
are playing Bishop to c4 they may even
say you know pawn to d4 doesn't really
see that that much but hey you might see
that most players are not really looking
for Knight to c3 but there's so many
different options and if blacks not
ready it doesn't matter if you're
aggressive it doesn't matter if you're
non aggressive you really have so many
different options to pretty much just
dominate your opponent so I really enjoy
this definitely feel free to get this a
try let me know how it goes
hopefully you guys enjoy this video
again if you haven't checked out the
website in a while
WWE chess website comm check it out lots
of great stuff on there and I'll see you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching